I have a porn and masturbation addiction
and I want nothing more than to stop I
feel disgusting I suffer from an
addiction to masturbation and
pornography
I fear it's ruining my chances of
intimacy with a woman I'm afraid of
losing my virginity because I'm so
addicted to masturbating that I think
it'll be the same with sex I feel like
my addiction to masturbation inhibits my
ability to interact normally with
attractive girls in my life I think I'm
a masturbation at it it's the only thing
that helps me sleep at night I
masturbate so much that now I don't feel
any pleasure at all not even the orgasm
I'm addicted to masturbation I use it as
a way to feel good when I'm down about
my life all in all I'm pretty happy
about my masturbation addiction it never
cost me a ton and I can use all I want
without fear of overdosing I struggle
with an addiction to masturbation it's
the creepiest problem and I would never
admit it to anyone because it tears me
up inside I got so sad when I realized
that sex wouldn't change my masturbation
addiction I have a masturbation
addiction as much as I try to quit it
doesn't work I go right back to it and I
don't know what to do anymore my
masturbation addiction is getting so bad
that I do it all night and end up sleep
deprived in the morning I think I'm
addicted to masturbation and is ruining
my life but how can I better tell anyone
I'd rather tell people I'm doing drugs I
used to think masturbation addiction was
a joke until I tried to quit for a week
what do people even do in their bored
Oh